Great, you've learned how to package
applications in a container images.
Which means you can now use tools like
Docker to not only distribute them, but
run them on a large range of machine.
This unlocks the doors even
more advance automation.
Now you have the power to abstract
away the gory details of packaging and
running your application on
specific operating systems.
Now you can focus on shipping your
ideas and making your users happy.
But this is just the first step.
Until now we've been working
on a single machine.
But if we're limited
to a single machine,
we're not going to be able to meet
the demands of today's users.
So how can containers be coordinated,
distributed, and managed that scale?
And at a even more fundamental level.
Should we even be talking about
running specific containers on
specific machines?
What's really important is that
our application itself is running,
delivering value and
being monitored and maintained.
And to do that we'll be using
a platform called Kubernetes to manage
all that complexity.